[Music]
elizabeth from roanoke she was um
smoking weed for
ever and ever and ever i'm in and
um she is calling with a pretty
incredible update elizabeth you there
yeah i'm here how are we doing
you know i'm great
boring and sober now right
boring and sober but but really really
good so i wanted to give you a call back
and tell you how it's going i okay i i'm
number one i always ask people coming
back and nobody ever does so you get the
gold star on your forehead today which
is incredible i don't know if that's
where you want to put a gold star that'd
be not a great place to put one um okay
so hey thanks for calling b tell me
about your adventure you've been on
so i have been sober completely sober
for 62 days today
and i've noticed some really incredible
changes in a lot of ways that i never
even expected let's stop right there and
what like everybody wherever you are
listening to this
and
there's
lots of you
everybody start cheering clap and start
cheering wherever you happen to be
grocery market mowing your yard and your
like dad's shoes your nike monarchs and
your tall black socks just start
clapping wherever you happen to be um in
your squad car whatever it is super
excited for you congratulations
elizabeth
okay
walk us back give us a 30 second rewind
when you called last time you've been
used in a long time right
yeah i had been smoking weed every day
for about eight years at that point and
i was on the fence about quitting for
about like three months by the time we
talk going back and forth back and forth
and my biggest fear to stop was that i
wouldn't be able to tolerate my feelings
and i wouldn't know what to do with my
time
and
that really stopped me for for months
quitting and then i'll be honest after
we talked i didn't quit i it still took
me a few days
how soon after we got off the phone did
you light up
like i don't know if it was immediate
but my feeling was immediately
yeah i want to get high after talking to
you actually i'm just kidding um
so
that's a very common thing i'm glad you
mentioned that often people will have
this big moment they'll have this hard
conversation
and then they'll go use again and then
they think well now it's all over and uh
and actually no like you okay you're
there and now let's take the make the
next right step right and refresh my
memory refresh all of us listening
was there a couple of things you were
running from what was the weed helping
with
well the weed i was really using to
self-medicate for depression it seemed
like my emotions i couldn't handle them
before and i would use weed to escape
and when you said you couldn't handle
them what did that what does that mean
like be
be specific for because there's gonna be
somebody listening out there being like
i can handle them i just don't get out
of bed for two days and i eat a whole
bottle of ice cream and whatever right
so
what does that mean i couldn't handle
them
so i think the two biggest things that
were so uncomfortable for me were severe
depression so the depression that gave
me hopelessness feeling kind of what's
the point why are we doing anything kind
of this total empty depression
and agitation
so if i was feeling angsty or edgy or
just uncomfortable those are the two
main reasons i would i would turn to
weed to escape that
and so you what was the day you said i'm
done
a few days after that i just was
wheezing again because that was one of
the big factors is that my lungs were
not healthy and i just decided i'm i'm
gonna try and i actually did start the
book you recommended um dopamine nation
i was listening to that on audiobook and
i was already kind of compelled within
the first few pages it's fascinating
isn't it pretty good it's amazing yeah
it's amazing dr lemke uh we'll link to
the show notes many other people already
yeah i i'll link to the show notes it's
it's just one of those books that comes
along once every 10 years and it's just
so good man it's so good okay so you
listen to that book you got convicted
and you said enough's enough what did
you do next like did you throw
everything away did you have a bonfire
what'd you do
well you know actually at the time my
husband wasn't ready to quit so
everything was still out okay i just
made up my mind and
that was it i made up my mind so i
didn't really mind that he was still
using or that it was around it wasn't
for me
like that okay and you can usually white
knuckle that for
a couple of days couple of weeks
what was after that
well that was what you know and i
remember like when i re-listened to my
episode that i was on which you said i
guess really stuck with me that i didn't
connect until i re-listened which was
this too shall pass
and that's something my therapist had
said too and i think that's been the
most powerful
tool for me getting through anything is
that the emotion will pass
and so if something was uncomfortable i
just remember it's temporary this will
pass i'm uncomfortable but it's not
forever
and
with this eye on the prize if i really
wanted emotional balance i really really
desperately wanted emotional balance so
i was willing to do this experiment for
that outcome ah so good okay so in the
past and you've been sober 60 days
62 the last 60 days in the country
there's been wild political upheaval
there's been economic people are
screaming and yelling and jumping out of
building like it's just mess
um it's a billion degrees all across the
country like
you picked a really dumb time to get
sober quite honestly and and if you were
like trying to get off cocaine this
would be a great time right but to get
off weed
this is a tough time how have you
managed this for 62 days
um it is really crazy out there um but i
would say just keeping my eye on that
prize like i wanted emotional balance
more than anything i i i became sick and
tired of being sick and tired that was
that was my last impressive episode
and i just didn't want it anymore so
despite everything else that that was
kind of the pinnacle like the the bright
light through it all was just i i need
to see if this is going to be curing my
depression and
i will admit the first two weeks were
hell like you said i think after the
first two days i had
excruciating headaches for about 14 days
like these really intense tension
headaches i was taking advil which i
don't ever take right and i took it
every day for two weeks i mean they were
that bad
um and then day 14 boom it was it's like
somebody peels off a cataract huh like
you start to see things clearly yeah
it's wild okay so
often i see folks give up a thing right
and they've been an addict for a while
and again we're talking about levels
here getting off heroin is different
getting off alcohol is different than
stopping smoking weed which is different
than stopping pornography and cheating
on your whatever but when people give up
things
and say i'm making a long-term behavior
change i'm playing a long game on this
one and you really tattoo this too shall
pass on your soul right
often they don't refill that gap with
other healthy behaviors and it ends up
that vacuum pulls them back have you
added have you started doing things like
exercise or yoga or drawing have you
have you back filled your life with
other things are you still hanging in
there
yeah
no i have and i knew that that was part
of it going in so i knew that it was
going to be part of the plan that even
if i didn't feel like it i had to do
something with my time and shockingly i
haven't had any spare time i've i've
easily filled it
i have my first garden my first
vegetable garden which i've been looking
forward to for years so that takes up a
whole lot of time
i did start exercising
i've i'm exploring the windhoff method
and cold exposure don't drive while you
do that by the way
you know i remember you saying that you
might wrap your little
prius around a
cinderblock highway divider just
hashtag saying
um that's fantastic man yeah that that
is actually the the wim hof breathing i
think is a powerful this too shall pass
because you begin to take ownership of
you go further upstream than this two
shall pass and you begin to take
ownership of the feeling before it even
heads down the road it's it's pretty
remarkable once if you go down that
rabbit hole for a while that's awesome
yeah all right
i have had no shortage of things to do
that's for sure that's so great you're
you're incredible you're like seriously
like i'm smiling and i haven't had a
great day and i'm smiling because
it's just amazing
here's the hard question so if i if i
describe it this way for some reason it
makes not for some reason it's pretty
obvious but it makes things less
difficult so also i can just do the
dishes i can just do the chores and i
don't have this extra
gripe and frustration and oh i have to
do that again when i remove that kind of
groan over everything in my life i
actually can do a lot more which also
then fills your time so it's kind of
been two-fold in that way who are you i
don't
who are you that's incredible okay so
i mean you'll you'll get this down the
road right now you're in 62 when this
becomes 90 and becomes 120 like the
this will you'll start you'll you won't
count minutes as much as you'll count
days as much as you'll count weeks as
much as you'll count months and this
will become a part of your life
and you'll look back and you've done
some
pretty extraordinary things because
you're moving your body and you're
changing your thoughts
and you are
getting a new connection to yourself i
mean you're making all these shifts
here's the big one are you ready
has your
um significant other stopped using
you know what he has what he's now 20
days sober dude peer pressure yeah i
know middle school style
okay so no i mean he made his decision
all on his own
listen constantly saying i feel so good
listen no guy makes their own decision
i'm just kidding he may have good for
him but there's a zero percent chance
that's true
and
if you all both need to tell yourself
that that's fantastic so
he watched you
just come out of a cocoon and he said i
want to be beautiful like that too
that's fantastic has he is he through
hell yet is he on the other side of it
he is yeah and it was about two weeks
also that's pretty miserable so he's
about a week in where he can see and
acknowledge color again
yeah and both of us we had some a little
some bad news some difficult news
yesterday and we got through it it's
it's amazing it's
it's really given us this both of us
this tolerance for
difficult things
like i said before with the depression
it's like if i was always like if
there's a baseline of depression i was
always kind of skirting and jumping
right on that line but now i'm not even
close to that line like i'm nowhere near
feeling hopeless i can't even tap into
hopelessness right now and that used to
be kind of just like under the surface
all the time so i feel really liberated
from that that's so incredible do you
have a game plan for when that when when
that siren calls do you have a game plan
yeah i'm gonna remember that it will
pass and it will pass and that will be
okay because i think it's when you are
in a depression you feel like that's
your whole world that's the whole world
becomes even heavier that's right but
it's not it will pass and it always does
pass yeah the the lie of depression is
it's always been like this it always
will be and it was your fault right and
one or two of those things may be true
but
in totality they end up dragging
underwater here's what i'd recommend
kind of like we have a fire plan
right like in my house i have a gas line
that goes to an open flame and i've got
two kids 12 and under like there's a
there's a really good chance something
catches on fire in my home right
um
we have a plan
just for in case
and so i would think it and this would
be a fun exercise for you and your
counselor to just say let's write it
down maybe it's on one piece of paper
and we store it somewhere where we know
where it is and this is elizabeth this
list elizabeth's depression plan
if and when my baseline goes low or my
blood sugar falls off and i begin to
feel like the old days or fill in the
blank right mom gets sick whatever the
thing is
i've got that map to get out of the
house when it's on fire already i know
where it is
and that way i'm not going to listen to
my body signals in those moments because
i know they don't tell me the truth i've
already got a plan from when i was well
and i'm going to follow that plan even
though i feel like x and y i'm going to
follow that plan i'm going to stay above
that baseline you see what i'm saying
yeah that's yeah
you're incredible can i ask you one more
this is a personal question and i can
edit it out if you don't want to answer
it
um
two recovering addicts
staring at it at each other
what's intimacy been like
you know you can leave this in the show
it's actually been much better okay i
think i mentioned to you before this all
was triggered because we wanted to start
to try to have children
and
that's been a huge change for us like
our sex drive has improved our intimacy
has improved we actually want a baby
even more because at least for myself
i'll speak for myself i feel more
capable i feel like i actually could
handle having a kid wow so it's been
really great there's something about sex
driving increases and that's a common
thing people stop smoking wheat all the
time
there's something else about
looking across a room at somebody
unclothed and saying do you see me
and i'm allow you to see me right you
know what i'm saying and so for you to
say no no that's that's improved that's
that's such an incredible moment for you
and your
ex
i'm just i'm like i'm so i'll smile all
day i'll smell all day well and i'm i'm
really proud of him too so i think
that's sexy you know like i really i
admire what he's doing and he's like
doing a thing he's the same
yeah gosh and you're going to catch him
lifting weights one day and then geez
louise man stay away from y'all's house
i'm so excited i'm so excited i'm so
proud of you
um
like for real i'm so proud of you one
last thing will you keep this in your
back pocket
yes
i don't i think i'm breaking some sort
of rule or something by doing what i'm
about to do and forgive me if i am okay
is that cool
if one of you slips one of you
uses one day
i want you to be about your new identity
not about this magic number okay
okay i've had i've had people who are
recovering from addiction in my life who
i love that their life revolves around
this magic number
and less about the person who they're
becoming and there's days that
um especially in the old days when i was
an idiot
i knew a couple of guys were gonna ask
me hey what'd you do for your wife this
week
and i would do it the night before i
hung out with those dudes so i'd have
something to tell them
and so there was something about
practicing like i'm doing things even
when i don't think about it or i don't
feel like doing it um there's moments
when that's good and so there's gonna be
moments when like i'm at day 2 22 i'm
not i'm having a bad day i'm not gonna
do this so i can get to day 223. there's
there's there's something there but that
number will never be your identity okay
you're bigger than that yeah and you're
that
this new sexy guy you found he's bigger
than that
and now y'all are on this new trajectory
in this new path and as two people who
are gonna honor and steward their
themselves and their mirror dude i'm
just like i'll smile all day because of
this i'll smell all day i'm so happy
well congratulations
thank you and is it all right if i like
share one last thing if someone's on the
fence you could share anything share all
of it yeah you've i mean you told us
about your sex life for god's sake what
else you want to talk about
i'm married
so i really would encourage someone to
just try
and it's really intimidating but if
they're dealing with mood problems like
depression that this is just a gift you
can give yourself to just try it and the
worst case is you get 30 days clean and
then you can go back but i cannot i
cannot believe how much it's impacted my
mood and i've struggled with depression
for
decades and so if i had known or
believed that stopping weed would change
and like liberate me from depression as
it has i would have done it decades
sooner so yeah if anyone's listening
just give it a try just try it out the
worst that can happen is you go back
after 30 days the best is that you're
free from depression and let's let's
extrapolate that out that's more than
just weed that's
um
your pornography addiction that's
working 80 hours a week that's people
who cannot put their phones down that's
people who are struggling with this sort
of eating
do something for 30 days just do
something for 30 days right and did you
find that number to be pretty magic
that's the number that's just constant
in the ethos stop doing something for 30
days and then reevaluate right
it was magic yeah i would say after 14
that was a real turning point and then
after 30 was even more so okay yeah the
the two weeks of hell is pretty routine
and then the two weeks of who who am i
what is happening
and then that back two weeks is often
when people just don't think about it
they unconsciously grab a twinkie just
because it's it's behavioral you know
you go to do the dishes and you just go
look for the bong and all sudden you're
like oh no right so staying conscious in
those two weeks as you're beginning to
see color again
i i'm just so proud of you and thank you
for your encouragement thank you for
calling us back we call me back at day
90 and day 120
oh sure and what if you ever have a new
day one will you call me that day too
sure i will i'm so proud of you and i
want you to send us pictures of that new
little
knucklehead of baby that comes along and
just hashtag just saying john is an
excellent excellent name hey thank you
so much elizabeth we're so proud of you
and thank you for like giving us a a
light to walk towards all of us me
included